aujourd'hui on a on a des mécanismes en
ont parlé du chômage sur des lits sur
les bas salaires il ya une telle
complexité dans le système dead de
soutien de poids et c'est au tour des
bas salaires qu'on a on a on a des
trappes à inactivité il ya des gens qui
effectivement se retrouve avec des
situations où il aimerait bien
contribuer mais finalement ce qu'ils
gagnent en marche bien des tellement
faible par rapport à ce qu'ils perdent
en perdant des aides en perdant des
soutiens qui l'ont pas il est
objectivement par intérêt de le faire
ils ont plus intérêt à récupérer des
aides travail au noir bon c'est stupide
alors il ya quelques yes a été améliorée
il ya la prime pour l'activité qui a été
mise en place mais on n'est pas encore
sûr un système qui est très simple et
qui est très lisible mais sur un système
qui est bourré de
d'abord qui est très compliqué et très
inhumain pour des gens qui sont dans la
précarité parce qu'il ya des guichets
dans tous les sens il faut aller passer
de la fois ils savent même pas qu'ils
ont droit certaine il ya il ya
effectivement un 40 % des gens qui sont
éligibles au rsa qui ne le demandent pas
soit parce qu'ils sont pas encore en soi
parce que pour des questions de fierté
et de ne pas voilà vivre une certaine
dépendance donc il ya des vrais sujets
d'accompagnement des gens dans la
précarité qui sont soumis un univers
assez kafkaïen très objectivement et à
c'est inhumain s et déshumanisant donc
tout ça on peut l'améliorer donc il ya
beaucoup de choses à améliorer un
système actuel je dis pas que mémé mais
il faut regarder l'art partir de ce qui
fonctionne c'est à dire la dynamique
économique l'économie de marché la
création de richesse et ensuite essayer
de corriger cc c'est les défauts cas là
et elle en a elle en a donc il faut pour
pouvoir effectivement à la fois créer
cette richesse comme le dit jean et du
midi est aussi la distribuer de façon de
façon juste
[Musique]